president Trump turning the tables on
the Democrats over impeachment demanding
Nancy Pelosi and Adam Schiff be thrown
out of office of her their handling of
the Ukraine whistleblower the president
also said to send a letter to Congress
demanding Democrats hold a formal vote
on the inquiry that's all happening
while a second whistleblower has come
forward claiming to have first-hand
knowledge of the allegations here's the
president moments ago the impeachment
inquiry zas cam the conversation that I
had with the Ukrainian president
zalinsky was a very good calm it was a
very cordial very good conversation the
mistake they made the opponents the
opposition the Democrats the radical
left deep state whatever you want to
call them they came out with a
whistleblower report before they saw the
conversation had they waited one day
Nancy Pelosi wouldn't have made a fool
out of herself
he defrauded the American people he
defrauded Congress he defrauded himself
and his family he made a speech as with
a horrible speech I said what does this
got what's going on here I think he's
having some kind of a breakdown that was
the president just a few moments ago he
was speaking in the Roosevelt Room Jesse
where are we today on impeachment you
keeping track of all the twists and
turns I have and it looks like they're
trying to impeach the president in
private I mean they're all doing this
behind closed doors they don't let
Republicans subpoena they don't let them
cross-examine they won't release the
full transcripts and they won't put it
to a floor vote and now you have the
whistleblower who has been found out to
have lied when he filled out the
whistleblower complaint there's a little
box did you have any contact with
Congress he didn't check that he lied
about that and we know Adam Schiff lied
his team had contact with the little
blower he lied to the American people
about it and he was held that from the
committee what are they hiding I mean
these are the same people that
investigated the Trump campaign using
secret warrants using foreign powers and
we still don't know what the bottom of
that was so over the weekend I did a
little deep dive State and have some new
information that I'd like to share we
now know that Joe Biden has lied twice
about talking to his son about his
business dealings and the picture look
at the photograph with Devin Archer who
was the Bur yzma official he visited the
Obama White House at least twice we know
now I'd like to know what he talked
about there also when the obama-biden
people installed their hand-picked
investigators over in Ukraine after the
Revolution they pressured the Ukrainians
to investigate Paul Manafort and as a
matter of fact the DNC paid one of their
contractors 70,000 dollars to work with
the Ukrainian embassy to get dirt on
manna fort and who did they link that
deep state dirt to Michael Isikoff and
that guy was the same guy who was the
recipient of the Christopher Steele fake
dossier and that's how it got pushed
into the bloodstream also interestingly
enough The Wall Street Journal has a
little rundown on the Clinton Foundation
it turns out the Ukrainians gave the
most top dollar donations to
Clinton Foundation over the years ten
million dollars you know there's just a
lot of stuff that we're looking at here
and that is why the Democrats are so
nervous about this because Trump is
finally dialing in on the corruption and
the collusion of the last administration
you know it's on this chart but stuck
out to me in Bosnia with 1 million
dollars I mean what was that for you to
listen one if you would to an MSNBC
guest she had this whole idea of how to
impeach and then not and then Pelosi
becomes president or something like that
watch you could impeach pence first the
problem is that Donald Trump then has to
name his replacement but I think that
maybe a deal could be struck where he
was told if you don't make a replacement
then Nancy Pelosi does become president
and so you are going to be impeached and
convicted you need to make this
replacement so that the proper party
contains remains in power why do you
think that's a serious consideration or
is that just filler for the cable
program I think the latter is I think
that's all fantasy I mean obviously it
is the case that the Speaker of the
House is the third in line to be present
so that if you if you if you impeach
both the president vice president then
Nancy but that's all you know silliness
I think why what's her name is wine
banks I think she hit one account there
so but you know the thing is that in
fact vice president pence and his aides
are now being subpoenaed they're very
much in this impeachment inquiry a
target and I think what's you know so
another fantasy dana is this president
Trump saying somehow Schiff and Pelosi
should be impeached now Jill wine banks
is on TV filling time but he's the
president United States saying something
that's just not positive you can't
impeach the speaker you can't impeach a
member of the House that's just not the
way our political system works what's
real is that there's a second
whistleblower apparently with some
first-hand knowledge of what took place
what's real is that Trump is throwing
his energy secretary
Perrie under the by saying all Rick
Perry told me to make this call I just
unbelievable what's real is there was no
administration official on any of the
sunday shows apparently not willing to
go out there but sometimes you take
sometimes you give the sunday shows a
break just having in the middle of
trying to fight this and if they had
people and the other thing that's very
real is that you have people like andy
card george w bush's chief of staff
saying yeah let's have an inquiry he
doesn't know about impeaching but let's
have an acre you have people like :
powell saying the republicans need to
get a grip that you know you can't let
this stuff slow can i can i play this
for Dagan there's somebody else who
things republicans need to get a grip or
a spine here's maxine waters on
Republican senators and what she thinks
about them I am disgusted with those
spineless members of the Senate who
don't have the guts to stand up for this
country many of them have defined
themselves as patriotic they're not
patriotic
they are spineless and they're not
willing to step up again this is
becoming a drumbeat from the left
against the right here's my wacky idea
this is why you don't put people from
the administration on the sunday talk
shows because these voices are louder
and they sound well it out somewhere in
space it's just off the charts crazytown
I want to point out let me quote the
Queen of Hearts from Alice in Wonderland
because this is what it's starting to
feel like no no sentence first verdict
afterwards stuff and nonsense said Alice
the idea of having the sentence first
that's where we are with these Democrats
impeachment and the removal of a duly
elected president by Fiat by decree with
the two hearings so far than the
Democrats and that were not just it but
in ask if so basically a secured
facility this is why people the more you
highlight this craziness and the more
that you try to sound reasonable and
sale
that's where the Republicans were went
on well there was Greg a former Obama
official mr. Brennan talking about all
of this as well do we have mr. Brennan
for Greg to reactive we would look at it
as a very corrupt government that is
under this way right now of this
powerful individual who has been able to
just corrupt the institutions and the
laws of that country what you say about
the stability of the democracy I think
it's no longer you know a democracy if
an autocrat is has it in his hands no
longer a democracy no well it's still
interviewing John Brennan after three
years of humiliating himself and being
wrong on just about everything look the
media reminds me of that guy that keep
trying to keep plates in the air at the
carnival you know he's doing this on the
boardwalk the Beach Boardwalk they are
breaking their backs on this story
they're like and the reason is is
because for the past like eight years
before to Trump they were like an
abstinent priest and now they're in the
red-light district under Trump and
they're they're humping the lamppost
they can't get enough I am so sick of
the phrase whistleblower because they
really aren't whistleblowers as my
friend Walter said Brennan's the
whistleblower there the whistle
answerers they're all come and they're
coming to help support this kind of I
would call it like a legal slow rolling
coup because they aren't really
whistleblowers because they're not going
against establishment the establishment
supporting them they aren't taking
really any risks they're getting Pat's
on the back so it's this idea that
somehow these are legitimate
whistleblowers no there's it's just a
lineup of people that they have to see
which one works and you know the you
know this story is waning and that it's
actually getting kind of fun because now
the media is no longer covering
impeachment they're covering Dems
continue to apply pressure on
impeachment that's how far removed they
are from this story now it's like saying
I'm applying pressure you know to keep a
horse in my apartment it's not gonna
happen yeah they're only I think they're
your wife's not gonna go for that no
they're not there they're already got
they got buyer's remorse they're still
on that carousel playground where they
keep the story going around in
you ever notice they keep interviewing
the same guests they keep interviewing
the same guests we keep saying the same
thing keeps going around and around
every week they keep saying the same old
crap but the media is pushing it they're
asking you to jump on but they're the
ones propelling the story yeah and the
fact that we have a second whistleblower
kind of reminds me of the second
Cavanaugh accuser yeah remember when it
didn't work the first time then you just
pile it on and on and all I think I'm
gonna pee with some more ridiculous I'm
gonna be a whistle yeah I'm yeah I'm
gonna go into hiding nothing you can
have a horse there that was maybe that
one or one of those tiny little ponies
well that would be the horse where you
should go the wine bank yeah yeah
[Applause]